delphine nadine et régine trois jeunes
femmes qui aujourd'hui sont très fiers
de leur réussite
les sapeurs pompiers qui viennent à
rejoindre les rangs de la grande famille
des sauveteurs pour moi c'est une grande
fierté parce que c'était difficile
d'arriver jusqu'à là aujourd'hui et vu
le parcours qu'on a eu en passant
d'abord par le volontariat avec du
chômage entre temps aujourd'hui je suis
fier d'être là où j'en suis c'était une
vraie passion depuis bat depuis trente
jeunes comme beaucoup je pense mais
c'est vrai que j'aime et tout ce qui
était coté militaires pompiers pour rire
et c'est le sport et ça m'a dirigé vers
ce métier parce que depuis l adrénaline
surtout les côtoyer des pompiers
les deux médias du sport donc
je me suis lancé je me donnais ces trois
ans pour être volonté à pourvoir
c'était quoi le métier et se trouve que
je me suis bien intégré j'ai aimé
les différentes facettes de son métier
qui m'a permis de passer le concours est
d'être là aujourd'hui
en tant que sapeur pompier professionnel
de progrès casse devenir pompier un rêve
de petit garçon mais aussi de petites
filles comme en témoigne la volonté de
nos trois héroïnes
c'est dans l'hémicycle du département
qu'elles sont venues recevoir l'arrêté
qui symbolise cette entrée dans le corps
de sapeurs-pompiers de la réunion avait
24 nouveaux sapeurs pompiers
professionnels mais également 39 sapeurs
pompiers volontaires dans les rangs deux
cousins d'un côté ludovic qui souhaitent
devenir pompier professionnel et de
l'autre fabrice qui a déjà la passion du
sauvetage en lui
monté à l'école mais
quand j'ai décidé c'était vraiment trop
tard mon âge déjà passé donc
le seul
tester mon héros
l'école pas pu fermer les empêcher
le moteur est pourquoi continuer ensuite
professionnels
il suivait les grades tissu je suis
sauveteurs aquatiques donc
j'aime sauver des vies donc
visible pourquoi pas toujours c'est
pourquoi nous voulons dire ben en 2011
on a passé le concours ça va drainer un
petit peu donc et aujourd'hui voilà nous
avoir
rejoignent
cette grande famille
de nouvelles incorporations mais
également de nouveaux véhicules avec un
investissement de 2,4 millions d'euros
trois grands incendies des recrutements
20 90 professionnels dont importance et
ces jeunes réunionnais qui va tous
passer un concours de sa bonté première
classe soit mayotte pour en métropole
donc c'est la jeunesse nouveaux
recrutements qui rit deuxième axe
important les volontaires être 45
pompiers volontaires qui sont engagés
engagé au service donc que des
réunionnais est lui troisième à ce qui
effectivement l'arrivée de véhicules
avec deux véhicules
le disque qui renforce sa présence sur
notre territoire et qui sera encore plus
à l'écouté de la population réunionnaise
avec la mise en place d'une plateforme
unique s'amuse 10 l'objectif répondre le
plus rapidement possible aux situations
d'urgence
car ce sont en moyenne un appel de
secours qui est déclenché toutes les
onze minutes à la réunion